我是江西的嘛，
然后我对象是西安的，
就是我已经是硕士毕业两年半了，
然后在杭州这边的互联网工作，
对象是比我晚两年，
相当于他现在是工作半年了，
那最近是考上了那个西安那边的一个市级下面的事业编，
然后现在纠结他不要过去，
呃，
现在的问题是什么？
比如说他过去的话，
然后我这边应该也会要过去，
那是因为我如果去西安的话，
首先我离他比较远嘛，
然后呢，
在那边也是地不熟的，
就是我的一个问题，
然后我第二个考虑点是我们定居的一个地点，
我现在这个工作也挺累的，
每天晚上可能九十点才下班，
然后之前工作之后也有各种啊囊肿啊，
各种病啊，
就是大大小小病也有嘛，
我觉得这不是一个可持续的一个工作，
所以也想着，
比如说我工作大概零两三年之后，
我也想找一个可以定居的城市，
找一份比较稳定的工作，
然后呢，
对于这个定居的地点呢，
我们两个之前有也有商量过嘛，
比如说我们之前都是在长沙读的那个大学嘛，
我们现在不在长沙，
或者说去苏州这样的地方，
但是我们俩商量了一下，
因为在西安，
他家里也在那边嘛，
就是我们在那边军信福感会高一些，
也有他家的那个帮式嘛，
呃，
整体来说那边的教育啊，
或者是资源还是比较好的，
所以其实在我这边，
我觉得西安也是一个挺宜居的一个城市，
因为那边房价比较。
低嘛，
但就是比较纠结啊，
怎么选择这个事情对于你来说，
就是现在你的工作你不喜欢，
因为对你的身体不不利，
就是导致你身体出了很多状况，
是这个意思吧，
你的工作本身也不是那种什么体制内铁饭碗，
也不是那种收入特别好，
人景特别好的工作，
是这样吗？
对我的身体有影响，
对我的心理上有也有压力，
然后呢，
工资是比较高的，
可能有两三万左右吧，
但是呢，
这也不是很稳定，
因为是互联网工作，
就我这几年可能攒了，
可能攒了一些钱，
但是呢，
我觉得如果再继续下去的话，
我觉得这个我自己的成本也是比较高的，
后面可能就是不能占比嘛，
其实我自己对我的一个情况来说，
我三年之后大概也是会换个工作啊，
也不太适合在那边待着，
就是整体性格啊什么的，
也不是说可以去选择那种性格啊，
你就有没有一种可能，
就是你的男朋友，
他自己先去一份工作，
先安顿好，
感受一下那边的工作环境好不好，
收入怎么样，
对吧，
那边的消费怎么样，
我怕什么情况呢？
就你俩话去到一个人生地不熟的一个地方啊，
他也是新到一个地方，
然后他收入也不高，
你又没收入，
你俩反而容易出现矛盾，
呃，
是这样的，
就是他应该是比如说确定下来之后，
今年可能。
然后在一月份就可以过去了，
然后我是打算我因为工作三年，
我可能明年还要再有一年嘛，
肯定是这边我可能在满了三年之后，
他可能已经工作半年了，
一年了，
然后我我再过去过，
这个时间段也可以看出来他那边那个工作情况，
以及整体的一个消费，
消费是怎么样的嘛，
就是从务何预期，
就是有一个时间暂是可以考虑的，
诶你想让龙飞姐帮你分析的是，
你该他跟他一起过去是吧，
因为他自己比较纠结他要不要，
对于他来说，
嗯，
他肯定是想过去嘛，
就在那边，
他家里也在那边，
然后西安整体的资源是也挺好的，
然后他那边工作大概可能到手也有8000左右吧，
就各种，
虽然基本工资比较低嘛，
但是可能就是各种福利加起来啊，
或者年终加来，
每个月到手也是有8000左右的，
这边来说给你是比较好的，
然后他也不是特别点的那种人，
假设你现在工作两三万一个月，
假设你到了西安那边，
你工作只有六千五千，
你能接受吗？
我今天打算如果我过去的话，
我也大概可能考个编之类的，
可能大概可能有七八千左右吧，
五六千可能比较低了啊，
七八千我觉得我在范围之内，
我觉得可以接受，
因为那边消费钱也比较低嘛，
第一你对现在的工作你不喜欢，
你觉得对你身体不好，
你想要换工作，
这事儿你就别把这账算到你男朋友头上，
什么意思呢？
啊，
你以后就不要觉得是我为了你牺牲了，
我为了你放弃了两三万的工作，
不要这么想问题，
你俩才有好日子过。
第二对吧，
你你西安这个城市你得多了解呀，
包括他的饮食结构啊，
对吧，
你习不习惯啊，
语言啊，
各方面能不能听明白啊，
方言啊什么的啊，
也不习惯啊，
你多多了解啊，
考编这事的话，
你也多了解政策，
就你男朋友能考上，
你这个能不能考上这事儿啊，
自己对自己的心里要有一个客观的预估，
嗯，
对于刚刚说的第二个点，
饮食之前去过嘛，
就是面食的话，
我自己肯定是喜欢，
比如说吃饭什么的，
但那些其实还好，
因为在市里面嘛，
他们那边都是说普通话的，
然后他那边本地方言，
我大概也经止了50%吧，
因为是北方嘛，
对，
然后跟第三个点那个考编的事情就大概有了解，
但可能就是要比如说选职，
大概准备3个月左右，
会有点难度，
但是这个花时间精力的话是可以的啊，
然后你见过他的爸爸妈妈了吗？
他爸妈就吧，
性格怎么样啊，
见过的就是他们的话也算就是呃，
性格是比较朴实的，
然后我觉得还是比较呃友善，
比较好相处的，
反正这事儿啊，
决定权肯定是在你手上，
王菲姐只能跟你说，
如果你决定过去了，
你怎么调整自己的心态，
日子好不？
会一点，
就如果你决定过去了就得永远，
这是老娘自己的选择，
我不是为了谁牺牲，
我不是奔赴谁来的，
我是选择我自己的幸福，
我想要来我就来了，
就千万不要去提那种说啊，
为了你，
我放弃了两三万的工作，
为了怎么放弃了哪个城市，
为了你，
我千里迢迢的来到这儿，
没有哪个男的愿意背负这样的道德包袱啊，
我理解如果不去西安，
或者我们两个选一个二线城市，
比如说在离江是地理二线城市，
我们两个去考个编制之类的，
我觉得也可以，
但是相当于对比来说，
整体去西安的，
我们的幸福网，
幸福感或资源会也会好很多，
所以我觉得相对比而言，
我觉得西安是一个可以接受的更好的一个选择。
嗯，
好吧，
需要你们辛苦了，
还有个小插曲，
就是关于彩礼的事情，
因为江西彩不是比较高嘛，
然后西安那边的彩礼就大概可能最高10万了嘛，
然后我们这边大概就可能二十万三十万这种，
就是我这个感觉这个事情也怎么去谈，
这个事情有什么建议吗？
我建啊，
你在哪里定居以哪里的水平为准，
那在哪里定居就以哪里的水平为准是比较好的啊，
这事就需要你自己来说服你的爸妈了，
那现在于是我先跟我对象谈好这个事情，
然后我们再跟对方的父母谈，
对吧？
自然会好一见，
就是关于彩礼这个话题，
你们都知道龙飞姐的态度是吧，
我是鼓励全天下的女孩子勇敢的要彩礼，
但是龙飞姐不鼓励高价彩礼，
也不鼓励天价彩礼，
从我的这个角度来看的话，
我说这话我怕江西人骂我，
从我这个角度来看的话，
我认为江西的彩礼是过高的，
当时人在吗？
有没有想骂我的，
江西的彩礼，
像他这种二十万三十万，
呃，
40万、
50万的都大有人在啊，
刚刚也有朋友说你折中一下也可以啊，
就比如说人家那头是十万块钱顶坎了，
你们这边是20万打底，
那你折中一下呗，
12万、
13万、
15万的折中一下也是一个思路，
在折中的过程当中的话，
还是要去多了解一下对方的家庭经济实力，
如果人家对方家庭经济确实不允许啊，
你要是要财礼要高了，
再把婚给整黄了，
刚刚有个朋友说他是江西的，
只要了2万，
江西真的是彩礼挺高的，
但是广东这边彩礼好像不高啊，
广东这边就是意思意思啊，
两三万三五万的意思意思。